sigamos estudiando las funciones de
densidad de probabilidad de variables
aleatorias discretas ok son estas
funciones que reflejan cómo se
distribuye la probabilidad a lo largo de
los resultados que puede obtener una
variable aleatoria discreta
entonces empecemos por definir nuestra
variable aleatoria y bueno vamos a
llamarlo otra vez equis y va a ser igual
a la cara que cae arriba al tirar un
dado justo de seis lados ok
x x es el número de la cara que cae
hacia arriba al tirar un dado justo de
seis lados ahora a qué nos referimos con
justo lo que significa es que cualquiera
de las caras pues tiene la misma
probabilidad de caer hacia arriba
y este dado es como cualquier dado que
usas para jugar como en el turista
mundial o en risc o para jugar mentirosa
o un montón de juegos pero bueno a ver
yo te propongo que trates de dibujar la
función de densidad de probabilidad de
esta variable aleatoria y ahorita
nosotros la vamos a dibujar
bueno empecemos a graficar esta función
de densidad de probabilidad de la
variable aleatoria x en este eje vamos a
poner de la probabilidad con la que x
puede tomar cada uno de sus valores y de
este lado vamos a poner todos los
valores que puede tomar x ok como es un
dado de seis lados puede tomar seis
valores no está el uno el lado dos puede
caer hacia arriba o el lado tres cuatro
cinco o seis y ningún otro no
y con la probabilidad de que x tomo el
valor 1 o sea que en el dado que tiramos
la cara que tiene el 1 caiga hacia
arriba pues es un dado justo o sea que
todos los lados tienen la misma
probabilidad de caer hacia arriba y hay
6 lados o sea es un evento de 6 posibles
eventos con la misma probabilidad
entonces que x sea igual a 1 tiene una
probabilidad de un sexto
y entonces a ver aquí ponemos la
y pues vamos a poner aquí la barra que
corresponde a la probabilidad de que
aquí está en 1
y bueno cuál es la probabilidad de que
x2 pues sucede lo mismo que con 1 no o
sea la probabilidad de que x sea igual a
2 también es un sexto
y la probabilidad de que x sea igual a 3
también es un sexto lo mismo que para el
lado 4 y lo mismo que para el lado que
tiene un 5 y que 6
es esta una verdadera función de
densidad de probabilidad pues x puede
tomar cada uno de estos resultados y lo
que esta gráfica indica es que toma cada
uno de sus valores con una probabilidad
de un sexto 'game' como hay seis de
ellos seis por un sexto es uno lo cual
significa que hay un 100 por ciento de
probabilidad de que x tome algunos de
estos valores y todos toman
probabilidades mayores iguales a 0 allí
es que si está así es una función de
densidad de probabilidad ahora cuando
tenemos una función de densidad de
probabilidad donde todos los resultados
tienen la misma probabilidad
entonces decimos que tenemos una función
de densidad uniforme como esta es una
variable aleatoria discreta entonces
esta es una función de la densidad
uniforme discreta si ve x fuera una
variable aleatoria continua esta sería
una función de densidad uniforme
continua y seguro van a escuchar estos
términos más adelante y ahora tengo una
pregunta para ti qué pasaría si este
dado dejará de ser justo o sea por
ejemplo si llegara alguien y cambiara
las caras del dado por ejemplo si tienes
la cara del 2
y llega alguien y logra borrarlo uno de
los puntitos
y entonces este dado tuviera ahora dos
caras que tuvieran un uno y ya no
tuvieran ninguna cara que tuviera un 2 y
bueno el resto de las caras se quedan
inalteradas ustedes siguiera viendo una
cara con un 3 una cara con un 4 1 con un
5 y una con un 6 como sería la nueva
función de densidad como sería la
función de densidad de este nuevo dado
cómo se distribuirían las probabilidades
ok velo pensando mientras yo voy
escribiendo esto
y bueno ya no sabemos si va a ser una
función de densidad uniforme y bueno
veamos cómo se distribuyen las
probabilidades de x usando este dado con
la probabilidad de que x toma el valor
de 1 pues hay dos caras del dado que
tienen un 1 cierto y hay 6 caras en
total por lo tanto hay en realidad dos
sextos de probabilidad de que salga un 1
o sea un tercio vamos a escribirlo
un tercio
y esta es la probabilidad de que x toma
el valor de 1
por otro lado cuál es la probabilidad de
que x sea igual a 2 pues ahora no hay ni
una sola cara que tenga un 2 por lo
tanto a la hora de tirar el dado
definitivamente no vamos a obtener un 2
o sea hay una probabilidad de 0 de
obtener un 2
esta es la probabilidad de obtener un 20
y pues como no alteramos el número de
caras ni la cantidad de cada vez que
tiene un 3 y sigue habiendo una cara que
tiene un 4 y un 5 y otra cara que tiene
un 6 entonces estas probabilidades
siguen siendo un sexto y bueno hemos
construido otra función de la densidad
de probabilidad de otra variable
aleatoria discreta y pues ésta no es una
función de ansiedad uniforme como la que
vimos es un poquito más interesante es
lo que resulta de lugar de tomar un dado
justo tomar un dado con dos caras con el
número uno y cero caras con el número
dos